the 100% correlation to opportunity in
2024 is how you produce content on
Facebook Twitter Instagram snap Tik Tok
LinkedIn YouTube period it is the actual
answer to the quiz what I'm trying to
understand is I kind of think you know
that so why are you not doing it because
the excuse is I can't afford it yes you
can all of you in this room by dumb [__]
order ever in your life from seamless or
Uber Eats dumb [__] ever Tak an Uber
dumb [__] have clothes with a logo on it
dumb [__] if attention is the number one
asset it's an interesting time a year to
give a talk when it's this early in the
year because everyone's what are we in
the 10th by now you've already probably
broken one or two of your core things
that you promised you were going to do
this year um and I I think about that a
lot actually the whole new year's
resolution thing and how hard it is to
sustain it and
really if if you follow my content or if
you've stumbled on it it's really
interesting about the two places I think
about you know I I use this term clouds
and dirt a lot and because a lot of it
is just perspective and then
execution and most of the content I put
out early in my career um and I still do
is very much around the execution like I
can sit here for the next 45 minutes and
tell you why I know most of you are not
producing enough content on Facebook
right now because Facebook's organic
reach and paid ads given how so many
content creators are overly focused just
on Instagram and Tik Tok has become a
huge opportunity like it was almost 7
years ago to drive your business and I
love talking about that [__] and I know
that some of the people in this room
right now literally just took note of
that and are going to go home and
explore with it and Facebook's going to
be a more important platform for you
than Instagram is right now cuz too many
people are stuck on Instagram not that
Instagram is not important it's just so
competitive that's why all your organic
reach is down right so I can talk about
all that and I can talk about a lot of
other tactics like for the people that
actually have time I posted this this
morning like the thing I'm most sad
about right now is that I just don't
have time and I'm not that guy when I
who I was in my 20s and 30s but anyone
who's got the luxury of time and has
ambition and I don't think you're at
this conference and paid to be here and
spent your time to be here if you're not
hungry or trying to make something
happen if I'm someone in this audience
right now and I have three four five
hours a day and I don't mean you have it
because most people don't have it I mean
when you really AUD at your time you
realize you're wasting three four five
hours a day on dumb [__] that you don't
need to be doing which is all of us
that's all I think about how do I get
another 15 minutes another 15 minutes
but if I had three or four hours a day I
would be streaming live on Tik Tok and
twitch constantly for my business
whatever you're doing here and like but
again it's a hard game the the biggest
issue for entrepreneurs Executives
parents the world is that most things
that are remarkable are hard and and
then occasionally you'll find someone
who blast it off real quick and you
decide to point to the
0.001% person that hit it
instead of realizing the 99.9% of people
that hit it after doing something
properly and hard for a
decade I know that if people paid
attention to what I just said right now
and go back and get very serious about
going live on Tik Tok and twitch for
four hours a day that it's going to take
them six months to get any level of any
kind of traction and I'm talking five
days a week which is 20 hours a week and
I know for most people after four to
five days let alone weeks they'll give
up because that's all I've watched for
the last 25 years when I talked about
you should get an e-commerce site or you
should do email or you should do Google
AdWords or you should do Facebook or you
should do YouTube and on and on and on
it's just you know as I reflect you know
I love this time of year because you get
a little downtime during the holidays
you think about different [__] because
you're out of your patterns and when I
think you know obviously I knew had this
talk early on I'm like how do I mix it
up what do I want to talk about I want
to talk about the fact that most of you
are just going to give up too
soon and it's because you just just want
it easier than it actually
is and it's really not about the tactics
it's about your
perspective so much of what is [__]
everybody up is they're worried about
everybody
else in two ways somebody else's success
is not taking out of
yours there is so much unlimited
everything money Fame opportunity so
much
that getting fixated on someone else's
success is hurting so many
people as if that's actually taking out
of yours do you know many people when I
put out certain things say well someone
else is doing that
already I'm like someone else is doing
everything
already there's [__] 17 trillion
versions of
me like like always like I laugh at like
people being stuck in like 40 years ago
mentality I was I just flew from London
so 12 hours I got to sleep a little bit
but I also got to do a ton of work some
somebody wrote me an email I was like
before I tell you my big idea you got to
sign an NDA I'm like
[__] but it's not 1986 up in
this [__] no more delete [__]
you and and it it was funny because I
took note of like I hadn't heard
somebody say you need to sign an NDA in
so long but when I look around and what
I'm trying to think through as I sit
with all of you I'm like what are they
thinking about that is over that isn't
real this is why I'm so fascinated by
perspective you
know life is what you decide to look
at like you know I I wish you could see
my social media feeds like it's like
kittens getting saved off a
tree like literally the post that caught
my attention the most today in my feed
was a post about two kids driving in
Massachusetts the other day it was like
a news article about it or like a clip
they were driving it was snowing and
they made the dad pull over cuz the guy
who was shoveling the sidewalk was in a
wheelchair and they were you saw that
and they jumped out and helped
him right it is
nice and and I get to see night [__] in
my feed CU I decide to focus on
positivity everyone's like the algorithm
social media no no it's
you you do understand these algorithms
are empty they just want to keep you
on I can tell you everything about
yourself by opening your phone and
looking at your
algorithms they're not trying to make
you sad you're
sad thank you for what he said
[Applause]
if I could leave this stage with
anything in
2024 I would make this the year for all
of you to finally be 100%
accountable like if I can accomplish
anything in this talk if one person in
this room just decides finally this year
I am going to blame 100% of the [__] I'm
upset about on
myself and realize that doesn't mean
you're GNA be depressed and sad it's G
to mean that you're GNA be happy because
you can do something about it we have
become
infatuated in pointing
fingers 2024 is here we're going to
point a lot of fingers we got an
election year you guys are going to be
real [__] sad this
year do you know what my favorite thing
is like rolling around in life and
hanging out with other entrepreneurs and
winners is when they try to blame them
not having a good year after they claim
they're so [__] gangster on a
president let me just give you a news
alert that you can sit with for the rest
of your [__] life if you blame the
sitting
President Obama Trump Biden Clinton and
whoever's next if you as an entrepreneur
blame the sitting president for why
you're not doing well you're a [__]
loser
I'm aware this is a very nuanced
statement I'm aware that macro things
happen under
administrations I'm just aware that
millions of people aren't impacted by
who the sitting Administration is and
they navigate through the reality of it
that's just the truth we have to get off
this kick of blaming our parents for
everything our government for everything
the platforms for everything here's an
important Nuance of what I'm about to
say because there's all sorts of [__]
there's systematic
[__] parenting really does [__] people
up governments do matter like it matters
that's not what I'm saying please
understand what I'm
saying if you are dwelling about it it's
already
over it could be 100% true you don't
think I have problems
you don't think anybody in this room
that there's not a person in this
[__] room let alone the8 billion
people on Earth that can't sit in front
of you and tell you 25 things that are
[__] up for
them as if the audacity that we have
gotten into in society as thinking
people have it good and by the way even
if somebody popped up right here and
says I do have it good everything's good
tomorrow they might not tomorrow might
be the day that their sibling gets
diagnosed with terminal cancer tomorrow
might be the day where they make a
misstep tomorrow might be the day when
they walk out the door and get hit by a
tree that would
suck why am I going here I'll tell you
why somewhere along the last 20 years of
living a public life talking about
business opportunities the first five
years I was so confused of like why are
people not doing
this like here it is ready I'll break it
down making content on the eight social
networks that matter the most will lead
to every single thing you want to happen
professionally as much of it as humanly
possible how many people here have
consumed my content raise your
hand how many of you have heard me say
that [__]
before so now the question is why
not I've been very consistent so why do
you not post 45 pieces of content a
day
bored yeah I mean like the the real
question becomes somebody will make an
excuse of like I don't have the
resources or the time that's cool that's
fine it's like you know I think of
business and I think about this combo
we're having like working
out right like you can like read about
push-ups like there's a lot of you in
this audience that consuming the
information makes you think you're doing
it that is true it's very true brother
like how many more [__] books do you
want to buy I got a new one coming so
buy that one
but but like how many more videos how
many more courses how many more
conferences for a lot of people
unfortunately doing the process of this
makes them think they're doing
it I'm not going to go to a conference
like this and never did not that I'm
better I I really need you to hear this
it's just that I just got raised in a
way where I realized doing the work was
the
game right and I actually think it was
my mistake to not go to things like this
coming up the game because sometimes you
need to step out like I actually regret
not having a mentor coming up the game I
lived in my own cocoon I regret not
coming to conferences on as a matter of
fact the second I decided to go to
conferences is how I learned about Web
2.0 and did my Twitter and like so I
don't think it's wrong I just don't want
some of the people in here being career
content
consumers and there is some career
content consumers in this [__] right
now it's kind of like the way we talk
[__] on the Internet or the way we
support [__] on the internet you think
typing it out on Twitter means you did
something
my friends 2024 needs to be the year you
finally do
[Applause]
[__] but what's interesting is the
reason I'm bouncing back and forth is
2024 if you're going to do stuff I
realized that it was the perspective it
was how you see the world right if
you're not in a good place it's hard
like one of the reasons most of you do
not produce as much content as you
possibly can is is because you don't do
well with the negative feedback when you
do or the performance of it not doing as
well as you want it to the the thing
that is breaking my heart is knowing how
many of you are not posting what you
really want to post because
subconsciously you're concerned that
it's not going to do as well as your
normal posts you're like literally
living your life for the
likes there's so many people that want
to get out of their Niche want to talk
about something else but because you're
used to getting 413 to 515 likes and you
know if you took every time you've ever
stepped out you only got 80 and it feels
like [__] you're just staying in this
pocket and we're just we just lack a
fundamental relationship with losing do
you know why I'm on this stage because
I'm addicted to
losing let me break it down for you
addict I'm addicted to losing now I'm
addicted to micro losing so that I can
macro
win the reason I got hot four or five
years ago in my content for the ones
that follow about eighth place trophies
is cuz we [__] the kids up with
it why did we [__] the kids up with it
it was well- intended we didn't want
little seven-year-old Johnny when he
lost to be sad I get it that's sweet if
I brought a seven-year-old up right here
you'd be like
a right but if I was like Johnny you
[__] suck you'd be like what the [__]
Gary
but I would be doing Johnny a
favor what we did for the last 25 years
in modern parenting is we demonized
losing we over
coddled which was in theory optically
looking like it was right but what we
did was we made them scared to lose we
took getting B's and C's and D's in
school which was already a problem in
the 80s and 90s and we took it into
everything we took it into places it
should have never been the the only good
thing about sports is it's non-debatable
you either won or you didn't and we even
[__] that
up and so now you have 22 year olds who
are just scared they're scared to lose
if they get fired if they this if
everything is the end of the world do
you understand nothing
matters
nothing besides the health you have and
the ones you love what
matters like this is why I am able to na
I the gentleman who introduced me said
something very nice to me backstage he's
like hey I've been doing this a long
time I just want to thank you because
the reality is 99% of people are not
authentic they act some sort of way but
backstage they're not nice I appreciate
you like that and meant a lot to me but
let me tell you why I'm like that it's
because when I get the claps and the
accolades and dollars and the followers
I can't hear it I don't think I'm
special I understand that I'm good at
business okay okay you're good at [__]
too I suck at a lot of things if the
world was predicated on how good you are
being handy around the house I'd be a
[__]
loser by the way I was a [__] loser
from first to 12th grade going back to
me being addicted with losing the reason
I'm good is because the world told me I
was bad my whole life when you get D's
and Fs in the 80s and 90s your parents
friends your friends parents and every
teacher every grown-up you know in the
world tells you you're a piece of
[__] so I got used to it you know how
easy it is to not give a
[__] when you got used to not giving a
[__] you like that
one it's true and then I played Sports
all the time I was pretty crafty at some
[__] but I lost a lot and you lose in
sports and I grew up in Jersey in
the'80s got into fights and got punched
in the mouth by the way that's another
thing we need to bring fighting
back I've come to realize do you know
why all these people talk [__] on
Twitter it's because in the 80s and 90s
if you talk [__] someone punched
you like I think seveny olds and 10 year
olds and 11 year olds at school and they
should fight
these kids have no idea they don't know
what a punch in the face feels
like and they definitely don't know what
a spanking feels like how many people
here were hit by their parent raise
their
hand actually stand up if you've been
hit by your
[Applause]
parent you can
sit
notice how that got a
Raz I promise you when I asked that
question in 20 years no one's standing
the [__]
up and I'm kind of like I can get there
mentally of like understanding what
people think about it though I think a
good smack in the ass will get you
straight
proper what I completely can't
understand is the fact that nobody gets
grounded
anymore forget about the spank people
don't get grounded and you know what
that leads to Growing Up realizing
there's no repercussions for doing the
wrong
thing and this is where we're at so we
can talk like I did for the last 10 15
minutes about the way it's coming up but
now the question becomes how about us so
it's been fun for the last 15 minutes
laughing about the kids coming up but
what about you because I promise you if
you were not completely where you want
to be you're doing something wrong what
is it what are you doing that's making
you come to this conference today right
some people want to Triple down on what
is I I'm sure there are plenty of people
here like good and they're like [__] it
I want to double good but I have a funny
feeling there's a lot more people in
here being like I can't get it to
click and the thing is going back to
falling in love with micro losing is my
belief the unlock for the majority of
you
is to get a little bit more comfortable
with this
Comfort losing and losing comes in a lot
of
forms right going back to again why it's
so easy to give a business talk in 2024
when you're me of course you have to
have business acuum you have to have
something to sell but do you understand
that it has never been easier to create
demand to sell something than it is
today that every entrepreneur 5 years 10
years 15 years 20 years 30 years ago had
it so much harder than than all of you
to create demand you can post for free
on a social network and sell [__] who
here is over 45 raise your
hand can you all tell these people how
insane that
is we grew up where you had to spend
money to get people to know [__] ads
cost money and of course you can spend
ads on social but you can post on social
for free that's when I that's what
really gets me crazy when people are mad
at the algorithms or the social networks
it's [__]
free like I'm Shadow band no you're not
you just
suck you're not Shadow band it's you're
not that serious I promise you you are
not Shadow band you just make content
that nobody gives a [__]
about you know why because you make
content that is
selfish you make content for you to get
followers you make content for you to
get likes you make content for you to
sell something to someone you make
content that is
selfish that's
it like has any do you understand
literally every time I post I look at it
and I'm like why would somebody look at
this that's it the Frameworks of how to
attack this game are simple executing is
it hard if you don't know what's
happening within
you right because you know I I think you
know this is a really again I love this
time of year I need to start making sure
I Victoria make sure I do a talk in the
first two weeks of the year every year
this is like real to me like this is
such a good time because you know life's
about it's like sports it's nice to have
a football stadium right next door
life's about
momentum it's
momentum right and so the reason a lot
of people not doing what I'm talking
about is the momentum is not in the
right direction they lost the stab they
were better three years ago than today
like you get caught but like again just
like when you know holidays you a little
something January want to cut down like
you got to get the momentum that first
day in the Gym's impossible even for me
I'm a workaholic and when I go on
vacation for two weeks like I just did
the first day back I'm like I want to
retire now once I break the seal hour in
I'm like no this is my [__] game but
literally like 2 hours earlier on the
first Monday I'm like I'm not doing it
and then by 10:00 a.m. I'm like this is
my spot it's like tough to right I'm
sure for a lot of you that's what the
gym is right no no no no you get there
and you get that Euphoria right or you
eat like [__] for like three months and
you're [__] losing and then you get
that one good day and you Swit like it's
momentum you must figure out what's
going on in your dome right here that is
stopping you I'm going to to say it
again back to school remember school I
don't know if I see some kids in here do
they have still have Scantron
sheets probably not right they do those
used to be my favorite I would just walk
I was such a bad student I would
literally walk into every high school
test if they were like Scantron I'm like
yes I would take it and be like C DB a c
DB give a give a
[__] not because I'm cool but because I
was smart enough to pay attention
that getting straight A in school had no
correlation to being happy and
successful just does
it there's nothing wrong by the way
being good in school as a matter of fact
I desperately need as many people to be
good at school as possible because I
need a lot of employees over the next 40
years so keep pushing your kids for that
robotic straight a [__] cuz I
need
employees um
no but what you know when I think about
this like we really really need to
understand ourselves because you got to
get the momentum because like a Scantron
a b CDE e I'm literally going to say it
again I'm going to recall it please I
need everyone to hear this whatever it
costs that you could afford of course
and cost is not just money cost is your
time your effort your energy whatever it
costs for you in 20 24 regardless of
what you do real estate agent uh how
many people here are employees of
companies raise your hand raise it's
fine it's good I know I made that joke
but please
raise for y'all just posting on LinkedIn
once a day about your expertise or what
you see in your work will lead to people
recruiting you to pay you more for jobs
in your same
sector the 100% correlation to
opportunity in 2024
is how you produce content on Facebook
Twitter Instagram snap Tik Tok LinkedIn
YouTube
period it is the actual answer to the
quiz what I'm trying to understand is I
kind of think you know
that so why are you not doing
it because the excuse is I can't afford
it yes you
can all of you in this room by dumb
[Applause]
[__] order ever in your life from
seamless or Uber Eats dumb
[__] ever taken Uber dumb
[__] have clothes with a logo on it dumb
[__] if on those three things let me
throw one more out there buy a $6 hot
beverage dumb
[__] all the things I just mentioned are
not dumb [__] if you're good
good but they are very dumb [__] if
you're not
good and it's a really [__] funny
game momentum because the more not good
you are the more you're buying clothes
with logos on it because you need a
quick little hit of feeling good for a
second this is one big game of two very
simple energies when I say one big game
Life is one big game of two energies
self-esteem and
insecurity and we all fit somewhere from
the extremes on
both and it is such a big deal because
let me tell you about extreme insecurity
it's actually one of the ways that
people use that energy to actually amass
financial success they are so deeply
insecure they go for it at all costs and
they figure it out the problem is the
people people that I've seen climb the
mountain with deep insecurity and get
there financially can't sustain
it cuz if you're dark you're
dark the other side that gets there is
called
gratitude there's that's the other fuel
you're just so [__] grateful for what
you have think about this no [__]
like do this for me please just for a
second if you can for just [__] 30
seconds with me on this one think about
how much energy in a day in a week in a
month you spend on what you don't
have versus how much energy you spend on
being grateful for what you
have it is so out of
whack it just is and here's why this is
going to give you the Insight especially
for the people in this room we're in
America it's too much
prosperity
world wars used to reset
us the depression re like the 20s they
were [__]
balling but the depression reset us you
were just happy you had a little [__]
porridge we just have had it too good
for too long that we're [__]
confused and so I believe that the
majority of you in
here's highest value
of accomplishing a business goal if this
is a business conference is actually
based on your perspective because the
answer to selling more real estate or
t-shirts or whatever the [__] you do is
content on social networks of course
there's other [__] but that is the
easiest and I hate that word but I'm
going to use it that is the easiest way
for good [__] to
happen and so we have to leave this this
conference finding a way to produce more
I'm going to go back to some tactics now
now that I think I've done my job to
establish
perspective I really really really
really want to talk about documenting
versus creating so okay you're hype now
you're like you know what [__] it Gary's
right this is my ear right cool you're
like you know what I've heard it enough
I'm yes now the problem is
tomorrow and you're trying to figure out
what to make right one of the reasons I
love this concept of documenting not
creating is I'm concerned that you don't
know what to
make which is why I love live streaming
so much be and I'm talking about live
streaming like go live at your desk
while you're working and have three
people watching at first and like while
you're on your laptop like look over and
be like
hey I'm being
serious but notice what I'm saying I
want everyone to hear this what I just
said is the content equivalent to the
first day you ever go into the gym after
not being in shape for 30 years and you
just get on a treadmill and you go super
slow my first workout 10 years ago 10
years ago Mike Vante and I were joking
about it the other day I did
eight atrocious
push-ups
I never built muscle before it's all I
could do if you're sitting here today
and you've done like two half-ass
efforts at making content on the
internet and you decide to live stream
you're just maybe going to be able to
eek out a
hay but I can do a lot more in the gym
10 years
later I just need you to know it's going
to be
hard and I just need you to know that
that's
good because everyone's saying but what
about this person what about them yes
they actually executed when I was
yelling at all of you four and a half
years ago to go on Tik Tok but you
didn't [__] listen did
you and so they listen they execute and
it worked for them sorry that you
didn't that has nothing to do with you
just because a couple people went viral
fast that has nothing to do with you and
more importantly the question is what do
you want to accomplish out of this I
assume again that this is the context of
a business business conference I assume
you want to grow your
business you can't sell anyone anything
unless you have their
attention if you go into the bathroom
right now in a stall by yourself and
start trying to sell something you're
not going to sell anything you're by
yourself you have to have someone's
attention to be able to sell to
someone the shocking percentage of our
customers attention now sit on these
eight platforms on these
devices it's stunning and the
opportunity is real the problem is it's
hard and most people give up and most
people don't know what to
say but all you should say is what you
know let me give you some tactics how
many people know what a green screen
video is there's like the headline you
talk over just raise your hands please
great so for the ones that don't know if
you've seen on Tik Tok or Facebook it's
like a human and in the background
there's like clearly a clipped from like
a newspaper AR or something it is
training wheels for all of you if you're
struggling to figure out how to make
content in your business or your
interest or your genre Google Real
Estate sneakers mortgages Insurance
apparel protein vitamins I don't know
what you do Google it go to Google News
look at the news find an article with a
headline that makes sense to you that
you have a thought on because I'd like
to think you have a thought on the
[__] business you're
in what do I do talk about what you
[__]
know take a screenshot of it if you
don't know how to do a Google a a green
screen on social media like some of you
are thinking right now good news I'll
tell you how to do that there's a site
called
Google you type in how do I make a Green
Screen Video enter they will tell you
for for
free and start doing it everybody here
can do green screen everyone here can do
green screen and it by the way as we sit
here today maybe not in six months maybe
not in three years but as we sit here
today A Green Screen Video will get more
organic reach than a normal video on
most
platforms all social media is about is
an acronym that I call pack platforms
and
culture you have to know how a platform
Works does a real versus a Main feed
post video work better on Instagram and
Facebook or does a picture work better
should you do a picture and then a video
should you do a two-minute video or a 30
second video what should the thumbnail
look like what's the first three seconds
of a video look like what's your copy it
takes
skill you should spend time at night
again how many people would like to grow
this year raise your hand
great
idea instead of at
night watching dumb
[__] why don't you consume information
on how to be better at making content on
social
networks you can you know and this goes
back to like what I see in my feed
instead of watching the news whose job
is to scare
you or watching [__] I I don't know
like blind marriage millionaire what the
[__] you
[Laughter]
watch people literally complaining about
their lives but watching three [__]
hours of Temptation
Island I get it you're
escaping the same [__] we do with drugs
and alcohol I understand or logos I get
escapism I just don't want you to escape
your life I want you to enjoy your life
do you understand that if you are
looking forward to Friday it's
bad I know this to be true because
that's how I lived my life from eight
years old to 20 I looked forward to
Friday because I hated Monday through
Friday because I didn't give a [__]
about
Saturn or the periodic
table or the [__] Dewy Decimal
System I like that recall that was a
good one remember that [__] if these
kids where is that how old is that
little
man 10 brother if you understood what
the world was like pre- internet it
would blow your little [__]
mind do you remember going to the
mall because you told your friend you
were going to meet at the water fountain
at 4:15 but for some reason their mom
got caught up and they weren't there and
you were like [__] it and You' see the
next day at
school like [__] was
crazy new kid came to school with a
beeper [__]
narc my friends this is it's actually
stunning how simple life can be if
you're willing to make it simple the
problem is you have to stop impressing
your mom your dad your spouse your
neighbor too many of you are living your
life for other people's opinion the the
real answer to the quiz of why you're
not posting enough is you overvalue
other people's opinions over your own
happiness it is really a
pandemic that's a real
one you've over do you understand you
overvalue your sister's thought your
mom's
thought you must make 2024 the year of
accountability
if your mom is super negative and [__]
you up do not talk to her eight times a
day talk to her once every eight
days I'm not saying cut your mom out
it's your mom you came out of that
[__] but if your mom is [__] poison
and you're a do you understand besides
that little dude and probably somebody
else said here you're [__] grown
now make 2024 the year you stop
complaining about the same [__] I got it
your dad drank most dads drank back
then I got it you [__] up and took the
wrong job you married the wrong girl
this [__] happened Donnie [__]
screwed you I get it and you're just
[__] in
it we can't like dwelling is a
disease and this is going to be a tough
year
like I said earlier it's going to be
super negative out there I am so not
looking forward to this
[__] these [__]
politicians as if they give a [__] I
love when you think they give a
[__]
promise stop stop feeding into the
[__] bad [__] focus on yourself focus
on your loved ones choose positivity you
have to understand if you have decided
to be cynical and negative It Is by
default that because you can find it but
if you choose to be positive and
optimistic you can find the two little
kids helping the guy in the wheelchair
shovel his
driveway you get to
choose actually you know what I've never
said this out loud I just thought of it
right here on the spot so this is
[__]
good let's make a pledge to this if this
talk hits if you feel like [__] it I'm
ready to go every single time you are in
your feeds if the post does not make you
feel good unfollow and mute that
person and then after you're done with
that that's your day to-day that's what
you now do that's what you now do or be
careful cuz sometimes it triggers you in
a different way if you find yourself
over envious
of someone delete and mute them too
because there's a lot of people there's
a lot of people that sell negativity in
an interesting little package they hide
it as I'm just trying to be
aspirational but posting pictures of
yourselves on private planes all day
flexing Rolexes is not bringing all of
you a lot of
value now I'm not going to blame those
people you're a big boy and big girl
don't feel bad feel happy for them but
if you're not there yet mute that [__]
unfollow that [__] and then when you're
done with all that the last thing you do
before you go to bed in that feed is you
go to search and you type in
positivity and you let the results pop
up on that grid and you click a couple
of things and you follow a couple people
and like a couple of positive things you
will wake up on April's Fool's Day with
a much more positive life that's right
whoever in this room is able to cut out
more negativity and bring in more
positivity in 2024 will win let's
go I'm going to leave you with
this so we just broke that down now in
June
if you're still in a bad mood that's on
you 2024 needs to be the year of
accountability the truth is and this is
tough most people are most comfortable
in dwelling in darkness you know why
it's
easy don't be that
person misery [__] loves company and
there's a lot of people feeling this way
because the lack of
accountability has hit an all-time level
but there are millions of people who are
thrilled and happy and living simple and
I want you to be one of those people
because I don't know if you know this
you were not born for a very long
time and I don't know if you know this
but when you die you're dead
forever and so we get to be here for a
little period of time
why the [__] are you not enjoying
it thank you Bay
[Applause]
Area